>> Trace: MIKE TOBIN LIVE ON
THE GROUND.
THANK YOU.
>> Sandra: AS OF YESTERDAY WE
KNOW PRESIDENT TRUMP IS NOW
CONSIDERING EXECUTIVE ACTION ON
A CORONAVIRUS STIMULUS PACKAGE
AS WHITE HOUSE OFFICIALS ARE
NOW EXPECTED BACK ON CAPITOL
HILL TODAY TO CONTINUE
NEGOTIATIONS WITH DEMOCRATS
AFTER TALKS AGAIN STALLED.
THE PRESIDENT CITING SOME
PROGRESS WITH THEM BUT BLUE
STATE BAIL-OUTS ARE OFF THE
TABLE.
>> President Trump: WE’RE
HAVING A VERY GOOD DISCUSSION
WITH NANCY PELOSI AND CHUCK
SCHUMER.
THE PROBLEM IS THEY WANT TO DO
BAIL-OUTS OF THEIR VARIOUS
DEMOCRAT-RUN STATES AND CITIES.
AND THEY WANT A LOT OF MONEY.
THEY WANT A TRILLION DOLLARS
FOR THAT.
THEY WANT TO DO MUCH MORE THAN
COVID RELATED.
THEY WANT TO BAIL OUT CITIES
AND STATES THAT HAVE BEEN IN
TROUBLE FOR YEARS OF BAD
MANAGEMENT.
IN ALL CASES DEMOCRAT-RUN
CITIES.
WE DON’T THINK THAT’S FAIR.
>> Sandra: KRISTIN FISHER IS
LIVE FROM THE WHITE HOUSE WITH
MORE ON THIS.
THE PRESIDENT IS CONSIDERING
UNILATERAL ACTION IF CAPITOL
HILL CAN’T GET A DEAL DONE.
WHAT EXACTLY WOULD THAT LOOK
LIKE?
>> THE SPECIFICS ARE STILL
BEING HASHED OUT.
AT THAT BRIEFING YESTERDAY
PRESIDENT TRUMP CONFIRMED THAT
HE IS CONSIDERING TAKING
EXECUTIVE ACTION TO STOP TWO
THINGS.
PAYROLL TAX COLLECTION AND
EVICTIONS.
>> President Trump: I WANT TO
DO THAT.
I DON’T WANT PEOPLE TO BE
EVICTED.
IT’S CHINA’S FAULT.
NUMBER TWO, IF THEY ARE THROWN
OUT THEY WILL OFTENTIMES GO TO
A SHELTER WITH TREMENDOUS
NUMBERS OF OTHER PEOPLE AND THE
VIRUS WILL SPREAD AND WE DON’T
WANT THAT.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP’S PUSH FOR A
PAYROLL TAX CUT HASN’T BEEN
WELL RECEIVED BY DEMOCRATS ON
CAPITOL HILL OR REPUBLICANS.
THEY’VE SHOT IT DOWN REPEATEDLY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP BELIEVES HE MAY
BE ABLE TO ACT UNILATERALLY ON
THIS.
THE WHITE HOUSE’S PREFERENCE IS
STILL TO TRY TO CUT A DEAL ON
CAPITOL HILL WITH REPUBLICANS
AND DEMOCRATS LARGELY BECAUSE
THERE IS ONLY SO MUCH THE
PRESIDENT CAN DO WHEN HE IS
TRYING TO SECURE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OF CORONAVIRUS RELIEF
FUNDS.
IF THEY DO NOT CUT A DEAL,
SANDRA, THE WHITE HOUSE IS
PREPARING TO ACT ALONE ON THIS.
>> Sandra: WITH THAT BEING THE
BIG QUESTION WHAT CAN WE EXPECT
TODAY KRISTIN IN TERMS OF
NEGOTIATIONS ON CAPITOL HILL?
>> THE TOP FOUR NEGOTIATORS
WILL BE BACK AT IT ON CAPITOL
HILL.
SCHUMER, PELOSI, MUTSCHIN AND
MEADOWS.
AFTER MEETING FOR TWO HOURS
YESTERDAY WHEN SCHUMER WALKED
OUT HE MADE IT SOUND THEY WERE
STILL IN THE VERY EARLY STAGES
OF THESE NEGOTIATIONS.
LISTEN HERE.
>> WE’RE REALLY GETTING AN
UNDERSTANDING OF EACH SIDE’S
POSITION.
AND WE’RE MAKING SOME PROGRESS
ON CERTAIN ISSUES MOVING CLOSER
TOGETHER.
THERE ARE A LOT OF ISSUES THAT
ARE STILL OUTSTANDING BUT I
THINK THERE IS A DESIRE TO GET
SOMETHING DONE AS SOON AS WE
CAN.
AND SO WE CONTINUE TO WORK.
>> I WOULD HAVE PLAYED FOR YOU
WHAT MARK MEADOWS OR MNUCHIN
SAID BUT THEY DIDN’T SPEAK IN
FRONT OF THE CAMERAS AFTER THE
NEGOTIATIONS YESTERDAY.
MAYBE THEY WILL TODAY.
THAT MEETING SET FOR THIS
AFTERNOON, SANDRA.
>> Sandra: A QUICKLY CHANGING
AND DEVELOPING SITUATION.